The Euler forward method is pretty simple again and the time
that you should find for the explosion should be 0.64.
This is a diagram resulting from that setting and this really makes it obvious that the solution
is escaping to infinity and a finite amount of time.
Actually, this behavior is not that much of a surprise.
X always has to grow because the right hand side is always positive.
The square is always positive and if you're adding to it and dividing by a positive number,
but as x grows, the square is going to become really huge,
so the rate of change becomes really huge, which leads to x become even higher and so and so on.
This is going to escape to infinity in a finite amount of time.
Footnote for the mathematically proficient, what we're getting here
is actually the shifted version of the tangent function.